tried a number of different things to
get Nazneen home we pressed him to be
brave much so I said in public I want
him to push forwards on improving
relations so so the underlying issues to
be solved they talked about how they
love complexities there and also to say
listen you you know you need to be
imposing a cost on Iran for holding
innocent people's leverage and you can
be brave there as well and and I talked
about this and I've had conversations
where the government is quite reluctant
to put it on his record I think you need
to in this case it's just unacceptable
to hold innocent people and please look
at ways of doing that so so we talked
through Jim Reardon I don't think I'd
come away thinking as he's coming out
tomorrow or even next week and I'll
think carefully what I tell her on the
phone on Saturday about where the hope
is to come and and I think this remains
that gap between my sense that the
government needs to be tougher with Iran
alongside improving relations generally
and the foreign office instinct to you
know not have things escalated and that
you know an administration that is very
keen to see the UK as an enemy and it
doesn't want to be and but we'll see the
other thing we gave the the Prime
Minister a little wallet that Nazneen
have made in prison in Evin prison so he
took that away and was touched and yeah
it was I mean it was the gracious visit
so so I'm deeply appreciative of him
giving up the time and for all the stuff
that were there so I think probably the
immediate escalation with with
particularly the assassination of Qasem
Soleimani inand then the plane was
terrifying terrifying in the way that
gosh what's going to happen and that
selfish level of what does that mean for
us in that just will we ever get out of
prison which was that's an increased
reaction and you know she went was
having panic attacks every night and not
sleeping and really traumatized and that
good answer to prison clinics we checked
and so on we talked in there about about
some of my magnets for sanctions which
can't at the moment but but once we need
to you you could do you declined apple
juice didn't you
farmers have made you some apple juice
and then you saw who did you see what
was the name of the cat's not Larry
wasn't it you saw Larry the cat you've
got a joy of Larry and you got a toy cat
in your show the toy cats gonna show the
cats I think many people come out with a
bag of object there we go
are you gonna call him Larry no not
gonna reveal what we calling him